it's handled you know her because you've
seen her so many times she's bold fierce
and unflinching seemingly invincible
black lady but you got me twisted oh gee
I'm always coming in media you can see
the idea that the black woman being this
super woman the caricature isn't only
used to shape fictional personalities in
pop culture it's also standard to which
society holds all african-american women
and it is that mindset that is passed
down to african-american girls and women
from generation to generation but
there's a problem I don't think it's
very sustainable at all and if it is
sustainable as a person survives living
this way we wouldn't need to take a
really good look at their health I think
the superwoman syndrome is this
suffering in silence hey fam I'm a Mayan
and this Sunday on aj+ we're looking at
what the ramifications are when society
expects black women to be super
two of the most popular dramas on
American television right now Center on
black woman with seemingly limitless
emotional strength scandals Olivia Pope
is known as much for her wardrobe as her
ability to endure and how to get away
with murders annalise keating spends
each season carving out solutions for
law students who refuse to stay in their
Lane never take a learning opportunity
away from another student no matter how
smart you need everyone to think you are
Annalise and Olivia have repeatedly
showed audiences how to win and those
wins almost always come at the expense
of themselves the fictional creations
are two examples of what clinical
psychologists jazz Keys calls the
superwoman syndrome black women are
always in this state of figuring it out
conquering it off being this warrior
being of inif intense strength the black
superwoman persona didn't originate with
Olivia Pope Annalise Keating or any of
the countless black female characters
who exhibit the same attributes before
the black superwoman character was a
part of any script or screenplay the
idea that was being handed down within
the black community in her 2011 book
sister citizen Melissa harris-perry said
the strong black woman stereotype was
developed to combat tropes like the
mammy the Jezebel and sapphire these are
gendered stereotypes you may recognize
the Mamie was born out of a pull Civil
War America longing for Antebellum days
she's an asexual grandmother type
dedicated to fulfilling the needs of a
white family much like Hattie McDaniels
character in Gone with the Wind who
literally was called mammy
there's the Jezebel which hyper
sexualized as black women it depicts
black women as having inappropriate and
insatiable sexual appetites much like
you see in many music videos and then
there's sapphire which you know more
commonly as the angry black woman
stereotype she's loud emasculating and
verbally abusive like Gabrielle Union's
character Eva and 2003's delivers from
Eva the super woman idea was meant to
buck stereotypes like those and now he
says it's become a part of black woman's
subconscious this is something that is
subconsciously embedded in our psyche
and also in others that black women can
endure so much or have endure so much
and still rise to the top
even songs dedicated to this idea like
Karen White's
aptly titled superwoman which spent 18
weeks on the Billboard charts between
1988 and 1989 that song is one way you
may have seen the superwoman syndrome
embodied here's another on the opposite
side of the spectrum I'm a strong black
woman
he says the mythology surrounding the
black superwoman can be as empowering as
it is detrimental the thought of always
being seen as strong and resilient may
seem complementary but the superwoman
ideal has some substantial negative
effects on black woman's health it's so
impactful that psychiatric nurse Cheryl
kis Gombe has spent the last 15 years
studying the psychological stress and
health of black women she's developed
what she calls the black superwoman
schema and says there are five
characteristics of the black superwoman
one is a perceived obligation to present
an image of strength the second is a
perceived obligation to suppress
emotions
the third is resistance to vulnerability
or dependence on help from others the
fourth is a motivation to succeed
despite limited resources and the fifth
is prioritization of care giving or
providing care to others in contrast to
balancing that with self-care kiss Gumby
says these factors are very likely
impacting black woman's health in ways
that aren't really being considered or
widely researched she added that the
superwoman schema can affect things like
sleeping habits relationships and even
diet the Center for Disease Control says
more than half of african-american women
older than 20 are obese
african-americans also develop high
blood pressure more often and at an
earlier age than their white and
Hispanic counterparts even within that
troubling statistic there's even more
worry for black women more of them have
high blood pressure than black men then
there's the effect of networked stress
that's when you carry stressors because
someone in your circle is experiencing
stress when we compared directly
experienced stress to networked stress
we found that for African American women
network stress was just as powerful
contributor to overall emotional
distress as was personally directly
experienced dressed his Gomez says those
stress levels may help explain black
woman's morbidity and cancer rates some
of the statistics related to morbidity
related to breast cancer may be
stress-related because african-american
women are not more likely to experience
breast cancer but they are more likely
to die of breast cancer and some of that
is related to delayed health seeking and
then there's something else could it be
possible this superwoman complex is
having an adverse effect on black birth
rates in the u.s. African American women
have twice the rate of low birth weight
preterm delivery and infant death or
infant mortality and it cannot be
completely explained by things such as
limited insurance or limited access to
health care if somebody says those
disparities still exist even among
highly educated black women she believes
health professionals should consider the
superwoman schema when researching
illnesses and prescribing health care
regimens she wants more researchers to
try and determine the direct links
between the superwoman schema and
african-american women's health both
kiss gum Bay and keys say a substantial
factor in black woman's health stems
from their focus on caregiving this even
plays out in fictional portrayals like
when Olivia Pope was driven to kill and
annalise keating spiraled into
alcoholism
they're the hosts so everyone needs them
all the time whether they need to make
decisions whether it be to fix things
whether it be to clean up messes they're
always the person coming in and being
the Saviour no one paid attention to the
fact that they were suffering in silence
until the point of them having a nervous
breakdown or turning to alcohol he says
even while these super women are
breaking down they're not allowed to
process their own emotions because
everyone else is relying on them the
super woman syndrome is that part where
often at night and you know we're
suffering in silence because we're never
saved no one's ever caping for us this
is a lesson that really resonated with
her after she became a mother my
daughter expedited my
process in a way that nothing else could
have ever done and I believe it caused
me to really take a deep evaluation into
what did I believe about my womanhood I
didn't want her to associate her life as
a black woman with your ability to
endure and withstand a great deal of
pain and still be able to say well I'm
strong enough to get through that both
Keys and disc on base say the first step
to ensuring the health of black women is
reminding them to take care of
themselves they believe philanthropy
starts with self at some point you know
you're gonna have to learn how to save
yourself and that is that radical
self-love and that radical self-care hey
guys thanks so much for watching don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
guess what we just started a brand new
show called because facts on Facebook
watch and I would love for you to join
us there we will see you next Sunday
when we are back with another awesome
video